71 years ago on a bright cloudless  morning death fell from the sky and the  world was changed a flash of light and a  wall of fire destroyed a city and  demonstrated that mankind possessed the  means to destroy itself we come to  ponder a terrible force unleashed in a  not-so-distant past we come to mourn the  dead including over a hundred thousand  Japanese men women and children  thousands of Koreans a dozen Americans  held prisoner but among those nations  like my own that hold nuclear stockpiles  who must have the courage to escape the  logic of fear and pursue a world without  them Hiroshima and Nagasaki are no not  as the dawn of atomic warfare but as the  start of our own moral awakening